ich kaufe nichts was andere ihm möchte
er lebt ja sie sind sehr clevere person
nur und wie ich sehe sind sie
verheiratet ja hilft ihnen der herr
gemahl im haushalt main
aha also keine stimmt nur kinder so
lange ist ein fauler hund stinkt weil es
dem multi noch ein bisschen ins hotel zu
machen sagt mir dass meine haut
putzfimmel wo gibt's denn sowas seit dem
release der sich zum gruppe in der küche
seien die fliesen schon so dünn dass man
den strich geschickt und erweckten tagen
kuchen kaffee haben ihr versorger schon
halb schwerin mit gebäck und seine
lieblingsbeschäftigung hizbullah leck
mich am arsch
er wird alles sogar zu erwirken und
dabei harmlos papierservietten
entwickelt sogar die rollen neu auf weil
die fabrik diesem zustand was machen sie
jetzt von mir ich wollte sie fragen ob
ich eventuell meinem mann zum putzen
vorbei schicken könnte
schenkel scope zur frau sie haben ein
flag bowl über das ist siebentägiger
kaschmir wolfgang mit essig wasser
nachspülen liegend trocknen wie man sie
jetzt klar machen dann ist ja mal wieder
trocken keine umstände ihn filmt mich
aber nie zurecht bietet sich allein so
richtig doch eine schöne entlastung für
sie ja schon aber wissen sie um geld
gefragt ob er bei uns schon einige stars
die zehn euro die stunde
was nehmen das alles ja und er kann
täglich um 9 und wenn er dann das
mittagessen gekocht hat und wieder ab
herzlichen dank
was mir dass sie mich anrufen
und an sonn und feiertagen da zahle ich
ihnen natürlich an die satten zuschlag
ist versteht sich da von selbst
ich hätte meine frau die das wohnzimmer
muss das im erdgeschoss herunten bleiben
[Applaus]